[Musique]
edouard marrant bonjour bonjour mes
chéris oui vous êtes membre du mime vous
avez été désigné par le comité patriotes
de rivia pilotes dont vous êtes le
président pour mener la bataille à
rivière-pilote pour 2020 vous allez
mener la liste de l'assemblée populaire
municipale de rivière pilote qu'est ce
qui vous motive à la motivation
oui c'est ma commune l'envi de de sortir
cette logique qu elle viable au tabac de
l'eau à cause des inondations ce que moi
c'est un prétexte
ce qui me motive aussi c'est cette envie
de voir de revoir de re voir fleurir
l'esprit pilotin l'image que j'ai vu
l'autre assure la martinique et même sur
le monde
c'est à l'esprit pilotin l'esprit
piloter un bain c'est cette fierté que
nous avons cette fierté pilotine à cause
du travail qu'a fait alfred marie-jeanne
et lucien meilleur durant l'heure le
mandat dure et on a été un exemple rien
pour beaucoup de communes un exemple
politiquement culturellement
économiquement et c'est ça que je veux
ça s'est stoppée donc il faudrait
remettre ça sur pied sa s'étoffer avec
l'arrivée de rimont théodose il ya un
arrêt il ya un arrêt c'est cet or est
monté au dos faisait partie de l'équipe
de vigueur de marie-jeanne tout ça c'est
encore plus critiquable justement parce
que on a vu en 2014
une liste je suis en format a4 pavé de
bonnes intentions et on n'a rien vu à la
fin donc moi je ne viens pas avec comme
le père noël avec
un paquet de promesses dans le dos mais
je dis toujours dans toutes les réunions
de quartier que je sera prise en semaine
et je continue de mener
je ne viens pas fait des promesses
par contre j'aurai un programme à
défendre et ça nous a libérés à me juger
sur ce programme
mais en tout cas ce sera pas une liste
de promesses
lorsque je vais à tenir compte d'un
certain nombre de choses telles que le
montant final le budget le budget qui
quand même ajouté sans cosse critiques
de l'opposition en place l'opposition
mime
oui mais l opposition mime qui ne se ne
se rebiffe pas qui participe au budget
qui parle à la gestion en tout cas le
retour que j'ai de l'opposition c'est
que il ya une absence de transparence
dans oz vis-à-vis de l'opposition et
même aux avis de l'équipe majoritaire
on sait pas trop ce qu'on fait ce qu'on
ne fait pas ou où la politique le projet
que le projet politique de l'équipe en
place on ne le voit pas alors décidément
rivière pilote depuis que le grand chef
n'est plus là c'est la débandade
il y a au moins quatre candidats ça vous
fait rire qui brigue le fauteuil de
maire quatre candidats issus du mime us
eu du mouvement indépendantiste
alors le maire sortant qui est un ancien
du mime il y a deux nil où ils régissent
un ancien du mime
alors il y avait juste biron mais qui a
été remplacé par vladimir veilleurs
vladimir veilleurs qui est le fils de
l'ancien maire lucien veilleurs membres
du mime et il y avoue membres du mit
comment vous expliquez ça là la grande
différence
c'est que je n'ai jamais quitté le même
ni de loin ni de près je suis dans le
même depuis très longtemps
jusqu'au jour d'aujourd'hui et pourquoi
pas les alliances on m'a renouvelé la
confiance puisque je suis encore
président du comité patriotes de
rivière-pilote donc ce n'est pas rien
est-ce qu'on est soutenu par alfred
marie-jeanne alfred marie jeanne a dit
lors de sa réunion le 6 décembre et
pilotes que il appartenait au comité
patriotes de de faire son choix est ce
que soutenait alfred marie jeanne
et puis chacun sur la question la
question est claire il a dit qu'il a dit
qu'il souffre qu'il vous souvenez me
surnomment les l'a explicitement est ce
qu il a dit sa vie de qu'alfred
marie-jeanne dit les choses
est-ce qu'il vous soutient la réponse
est claire il a dit en réunion publique
le 6 décembre à rivière pilote qu'il
appartenait au haut comité patriotes de
faire son choix
le comité patriotes a choisi a choisi
est candidat edouard ans et ses
candidats porté par les militants les
sympathisants et la population puisque
avant même qu'on me propose d'être
candidat
j'avais été sollicité par la population
donc en toute logique en toute logique
comme il a laissé le choix aux comités
patriotes mais c'est le candidat du
comité patriotes
oui vous parlez pour alfred marie-jeanne
messine au talent de chiots japon chez
edouard maroc je vous remercie les cinq
minutes sont écoulées
merci beaucoup